Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg is
testifying this morning on Capitol Hill
his hearing is supposed to be about
cryptocurrency but that is not likely to
be the only line of questioning from
members of Congress ed O'Keefe is
outside the hearing room bed good
morning so what are the issues on the
minds of Zuckerberg but also the
committee members
well good morning Tony when Zuckerberg
appears here today before the House
Financial Services Committee he set to
push lawmakers and federal regulators to
take a more active role in policing
harmful content online protecting
elections and improving online security
but members of both parties are poised
to push him to explain what he's doing
on those issues
Zuckerberg appearance here comes just
days after Facebook announced it will
more prominently label posts that
include false or partially false
information they're also launching new
tools to help political candidates
monitor social media accounts for
potential hacking but Facebook and
Instagram will still allow political
candidates to advertise with few
restrictions that certain criticism
especially from Democratic presidential
candidates who say Facebook is helping
president Trump spread lies about his
potential opponents Zuckerberg says it
shouldn't be up to tech companies to
decide what you can and cannot see
online so whether it's crypto currency
or election interference this is a
reminder Facebook plays a big role in
the lives of millions of Americans and
billions around the world and Gayle he's
set to face a rough day in the witness
chair all right we'll all be watching
thank you very much